i'm not prepared for this  three two one go for ignition  [Music]  july 20th  1969.  that's one small step for man  martin luther  school you were taught that apollo 11  lost contact with the world for two  minutes not true  they found something on that day  that they kept him for 50 years  and now  it's too late to stop  in breaking news the governor has just  ordered the mass evacuation of the  entire west coast moving to higher  ground it's the only possible chance of  surviving  stay away from my brothers and sisters  stay awake  this planet  has suffered five extinctions  this  is going to be the sixth  oh he dead  no we are just inside the moon that  might be the greatest sentence anyone's  ever said  [Music]  [Music]  you